i'm going to get started on the work
session
for house ways and means
on four senate bills and we hope to do a
concurrence on another bill this morning
we'll start with
senate bill 316 relative to lucky seven
licenses
and
first of all
does anybody have any questions or open
items that we want to discuss on 316.
representative romney yeah
i'd like to ask the lottery to come up
one more time said possible mr
this representative romney do you want
them to introduce themselves
yeah
good morning mr chairman members of the
ways and means committee i'm charlie
mcintyre uh director of the new
hampshire lottery with me is
our head of licensing
okay so
this morning i was we were going through
the bill i just want to double i asked
this question two three times
last time because there's three
three three types of uh organization
types that have lucky seven and bingo
and that's
uh charitable gaming maybe four or five
sites
then there's the bingo halls
uh that's maybe
around 15 maybe sites
and then there's uh
fraternal organizations and there's a
lot of those
so i just want to make sure that this
bill
just impacts
charitable gaming locations
is that something you can
just verify for me please yes that's
correct um by charitable gaming halls
you mean games of chance halls so yes
there's games of chance which are
actually licensed as commercial bingo
halls they can't
they they will be able to operate them
under this bill but currently they are
not
so yes that well they have dual license
correct correct but currently they have
right they have a terrible gaming
license i i call it that and then
then they have a license for bingo
currently yes which and follow
the license for bingo gives them
uh the right to to to do lucky seven
correct correct
there is no lucky seven license or or is
it
well
currently with lucky seven the charity
has the license
that's right right
okay
so
so with that so this only is going to
impact there's no impact on fraternal
halls or the other
the other uh bingo halls if you will
right essentially this bill will allow
the games of chance halls to operate
without having to
get a separate commercial bingo hall
license right but they'd operate in the
same way right and if they want if they
want to offer
if they want to offer lucky seven they
can offer lucky seven
is what you're saying okay thank you
anybody else
questions
well we have the lottery commissioner
here
thank you thank you
now
without any further questions
if we were to exact this bill
now
i'm taking a straw poll
who who would support executive
who would not support an executive
then
representative brown you want to make a
motion
make a motion of the past uh we're going
into executive sectors
i make a motion ought to pass
second
representative romney makes promotion
about to pass
second by representative lange
representative romney
uh thank you mr chair i think i've
pretty much through my questions i've
explained the situation uh but this this
is going to impact a handful of uh
charitable gaming locations out of the
16 that we have
uh
being as we know bingo is dying
but lucky seven has always been the been
the backup to uh keep bingo alive
uh so so with that i think we just
vote ought to pass on this and move
forward
any further questions or comments
saying none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the vote thank you mr chair the
bill is senate bill 316 the motion is
out to pass we will begin the voting
with representative abrami yes
representative owry
yes
representative doucette
representative lang yes the clerk votes
yes representative genigion yes
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative tudor yes
representative army
representative ames yes
representative malloy
yes
represent the honorable thomas c
schomburg
yes mr court thank you
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo yes
representative murphy yes
chairman major yes
did i not call anyone's name
but it's 17 to them
the vote being 17 to zero the motion of
autop ought to pass passes
and without objection
it will go on consent
i see no objection so it will appear on
the consent calendar
now we go back to work session
and the next bill on the work session is
senate bill 318-fn
expanding the hours in which games a
chance may be conducted
and the big thing on this is that
the bill allows expansion
from starting
at 11 in the mornings to start at eight
and
ending
at one
change it to four
so that is the issue
questions or comments
but representative elmi
thank you
there are a lot of municipalities
um
well
that don't
have
haven't put
restrictions on operating
hours
and some of them at least mine
has a game
of chance so-called a poker hall it's
about to become a mini casino
on
which
is in the middle of a
half residential half commercial
district
that
has a number of emergency
services
that have to be opened
at night which makes it difficult to do
a restriction
on
places that would uniformly
be
requiring parking that they won't have
at night during the winter
and on
doing on
perhaps serving liquor long past the
hours that the liquor commission is
working
on and
coming in
and going and maybe making noise who
knows
uh
and
i want i mean this and this is something
that nobody really seems to have thought
about they just decided it would be a
nice thing to do
on
this this business about people relaxing
before they go to bed by
by either uh winning something and going
home all excited or not winning
something and going home all depressed
seems a little weird uh to me but
i would like
i i am opposed to this bill if this bill
is passing
i would like
specification that the municipalities
can
undo it locally if they
are in a position where
it does damage to the community around
it
and by emergency services i mean too
uh shelters
one for recovering alcoholics and one
for
abused spouses
on
that have to take people in in the
middle of the night sometimes and the
fire department
which has to operate
at night
sometimes
thank you
further comments
followed by representative romney uh
thank you mr chair i appreciate what
representative all me has brought up my
only concern was
the the late hour i consider that a
problem i think
four o'clock is really late especially
when liquor is no longer served after 1
30.
i feel that if there's going to be a
a passage of this that the time limit
should be changed maybe to 2 30.
it gives the person that has
had their last drink at least a good
hour to
allow the alcohol to
be disposed from their body
so uh
i feel that there should be a time limit
in the morning four o'clock is just too
early too late
well thank you uh representative
representative romney may have a
solution
uh thank you mr chair
um
so
i i agree with you representative
schomburg
um i
it's
this is charitable gaming this is not
vegas this is not new york bars are an
open you know well the casinos aren't
open around the clock
uh our terrible gaming locations i don't
think should be open around the clock
either
and uh
i think a compromise would be to expand
the hours slightly
um
i originally thought adding
talking about alcohol
as we we talked about on the in the
hearing
alcohol is served in the state from
6 a.m
to 1 p.m
and then
served
1am i'm sorry to 1am
with
with a half an hour to be on the on the
table and after a half hour that no
drink should be should appear on the
table it's and again we serve alcohol
in places that serve food
which basically the restaurants
so
i was thinking that right now our
charitable gaming locations are open
from 14 hours 11 a.m to
uh
to 1 a.m
i think a reasonable compromise is to
have them open 16 hours which basically
is two shifts
and we can we can do something like from
10 a.m to 2 p.m
um
a.m thank you
and that's 16 hours
i i suggest taking baby steps here uh
given its charitable gaming
um and i'm open to any any variation on
that
representative schomburg is suggesting
uh
two o'clock
uh or two or uh
one to one two thirty
um
which is uh an hour and a half after
drinks are served
um i could probably live with that
and or just keep it keep it 11 a.m
and and go to 2 30 or go from 2 10 30 in
the morning to 2 30. as long as the 16
hours is that maybe maybe that's what
we'll do suggest so 10 30 a.m
to
2 30 a.m and that adds
that adds one hour or two hours to the
day that the
charitable location can be open
no not yet it's a discussion that's a
discussion that that's what i'm i'm
going to suggest as a compromise 10 30
am
to 2 30 to 2 30
a.m okay further discussion or
options
representative alani
who is supposed to be enforcing this
at night
when it's closed
well you probably can't tell in our
place because they blacked out all the
windows
but on
when it's closed
on
you may be able to
somebody passing may notice
that it's open if it's open past the
hours it's supposed to be but they
certainly aren't going to notice
unless they go play themselves
on
whether they're serving alcohol
after the 1am that is allowed
of course going
going to that is very difficult also
especially when you blacked out all the
windows
representative
ames
just a question to representative ramy
um
how do you uh
respond to this
the proposal that municipalities
be given the option to
explicitly given the option
to uh
have a different
hourly limit than the one that
in the end is
identified in this bill
representative rodney
so what you're suggesting is that an
ordinance be allowed
to
restrict the time
um
i think we had this conversation the
other day about the ordinances and um
uh
it's my understanding from that
conversation that the town can have an
ordinance that restricts certain times
currently
so i think that provision already exists
uh and if they want to restrict the 101
right now it's to one o'clock
they could probably restrict it to 12
o'clock now or or to 11 pm
before you go further
charlie
is what representative romney just
expressed is that correct
yes mr be my understanding there are
jurisdictions which place limits not
outright bans but limits on the location
and time of these places and we would
honor that like for example i know salem
has a limitation on where the facilities
can be located within its town based on
its zoning laws it just can't
outright ban them that's all
okay and so if they had an ordinance say
you have to close at 11 at night
correct we would we would honor and
enforce that to the extent we could
thank you
representative romney you have anything
else
but that answers
do you have anything else
well i guess i do uh
that is uh
i don't really question uh mr mcintyre's
statement but um why not be absolutely
sure about it uh this is just an
authorization
they'll be statewide to conduct
games of chance between certain hours
and
the um
to be clear why not have a provision and
hit here that uh says provided that
municipalities through their
local ordinances and zoning rules may
uh provide further limitations or
something like that why not be clear on
it that's all i'm saying
representative romney
i have no objection to that
anybody else knew
okay representative almighty thank you i
on
i understand what uh mr mcintyre is
saying
but
i'm not sure that this is the law
in new hampshire particularly given how
many exemptions charitable gaming in
general the law of charitable gaming has
against municipal
on requests
on we do we don't have a
night ordinance but what we or in
general but what we do have
is a parking ordinance during the winter
when the snow is
getting deep
which
says that
they put something out and they say
and i'm not sure
under what circumstances but they put it
out and they say no one can park in the
parking areas
which
means that they would people would have
to walk quite a long way to get to this
place after i think it's 11 o'clock at
night
and before some hour in the morning that
i forget when that one is
and that is so the snowplows
can go out and get finished with all the
mess
that's in downtown
um
i'm not sure how that would be covered
in this particular case but i do know
that they will continue to
issue that warning and will probably end
up towing a lot of people
representative
thank you mr chair
um representative tucker brought up
something earlier when we were chatting
about
people leaving with cash at that hour of
the morning
and some municipalities not having a 24
7 police force
so i was wondering and i'm sorry charlie
sat back down but
do
these facilities have their own security
so if someone did have a bundle on them
they could be escorted to their vehicle
jolly
good morning again
thank you for the question uh yes all
these facilities have their own security
force most of them are ex police
and as part of our requirements for
their facility we have specific
requirements regarding cash management
and surveillance and security um that i
could share with you privately but not
publicly because as you could imagine i
don't want folks to see you know public
record of all the surveillance
requirements and but i'd have to share
with you if you would like but yes
thank you very much
representative romney
so the uh what was brought up before
this discussion was the enforcement of
uh you know meaning that
from one o'clock to 230
um
would there be any change in enforcement
from your your standpoint it wouldn't i
mean certainly to the extent we'd be
relying on local police to a certain
extent we have heard rumors of
after hours games occurring and we do
issue warnings but i don't have staff
out at three in the morning for example
but you don't have to staff out to one
o'clock in the morning now um we have
staff at night yes but not to 1am no
okay but they don't cover all 16
facilities at the same time no no no i
don't have the level of staff we have um
five auditors and uh five full five
full-time investigators and two
part-timers uh but they it's more random
okay thank you
uh we're up down nearly
thank you uh charlie it would take one
guy over time
to stop
after hours keep one
the word would travel really quickly
regarding this particular bill however
there are some people that indicate that
it would uh that additional language
would be unnecessary but i tend to agree
with uh
with my colleagues on the left that uh
making something clear in law
just makes sense particularly if that
means you can gain uh unanimous support
and eliminate a floor pipe over
words
um
so
i would be in favor of a uh
a modification something to the effect
that says that nothing in this bill
shall allow a regulated
entity to operate
beyond the hours allowed by local
ordinance i mean it's
it just says clearly yeah you can
operate until four o'clock if the town
says you can operate until four o'clock
okay
represent the lane
apparently i'm in the monarchs i'm okay
with the bill is written um and i just
like that and talk to some of the
questions and and i guess charlie
one question i have for you is relative
to
i'm assuming any after hours or any uh
just like liquor anything that's done
after hours is generally a complaint
based investigation someone would
probably form a complaint saying i think
these people are gambling after hours
and then you would assign an
investigator and then research that is
that that's correct that's great like
any violation of the law or rule that's
exactly how it would happen and then
they would we have the authority now to
find them or
serve a licensed suspension the
equivalent yes thank you charlie for
instant so
going back mr chair so talking to things
like liquor enforcement again this is
the same kind of activity if there's a
complaint based liquor will sign an
investigation investigator will then
investigate whether or not a given
entity is is violating liquor law by
serving after one o'clock or 1 30 if it
the drinks are on the table
i go back to my municipal hat and and as
my the chairman of my zoning board and
understanding how planning boards work
um in businesses when a business comes
forward in a town or city it must go
through a site plan review to open up in
that site plan review they have
things like health and safety so i use
the example of agri-tourism when we
authorized agritourism representative
tucker did a nice article on on a bill
we pushed through about agritours and we
allow weddings at farms
and yet that doesn't mean they can have
a wedding until four in the morning it
means that the town planning department
puts together the conditions lighting
and health and safety and parking and
all the requirements that are needed for
a business to open and for an activity
to occur and then those guidelines are
put in place
so
again if the existing site plans have a
as part of the business operations which
is one of the requirements that you do
the hours of operation is is in your
site plan review
if that's going to change for a given
business they must go in front of their
local planning board and get a change to
the existing site plan
so i i'm really hesitant to put in
you know we look at
noise ordinance is one of the comments
if it's too loud towns have every right
to put a noise ordinance in if you can
say you can't have noise after one
o'clock in the morning
and then we you town's gonna local
police can enforce those ordinances so
again i'm really hesitant to start doing
carve-outs for special businesses and
special cases um i've heard a lot of i
think i believe i'm not sure um but the
bottom line is we're kind of making a
passing judgment on people who stay out
to four in the morning and choosing the
game
which i don't think we should be doing
either if the person works the shift and
they choose to work the night and go
they want to spend their evening going
having a drink after midnight and and
play some games before they go to bed
because they get off the second shift
that's not us to judge them on what kind
of citizens they are
um i think this ordinance plays this law
as it moves forward it would be
appropriate to allow to take into a most
citizens and what they allow it still
gives towns all the needed control they
have through the site plan review
through creating noise ordinances if
they want creating parking ordinances if
they want none of that takes away from
any of this
i think this bill is just simply
allowing businesses acknowledging that
we have a 24-hour workforce
and that
we acknowledge that people have the
right to do what they want to do when
they want to do it for within limited
con conditions and that
again
we should not be doing carve out say
this for this one business we're going
to create this whole new ordinance just
for one town or for one reason again i i
i support the bill as written for all
the reasons i've said i think it's
inappropriate to allow the business to
manage the business if the hours doesn't
work and and i think we heard testimony
there's probably only one or two that
would even consider staying open and
even then probably only on weekends um
i i don't know i don't know why we would
put further restrictions or deny them
the right to be able to make a living if
they think they can
representation
uh we uh
relaxing the restrictions that we have
right now
exactly and i think that's a smart move
again if they think it's needed they'll
help them in their business model and
help the charities so remember again
this means that charities are getting
more money by having more hours of
operation so
um
i agree this is a relaxing of rules and
and i think that the more we can do and
relax there hasn't been complaints from
any of the conversation we've had
anywhere
nobody said that at two o'clock in the
morning we have have a problem um and so
it's all speculation at this point so
yes i would like to relax the rules and
make it better for this environment
and
it could be relaxing on a glide
glide path
adding an hour or so each way
i do believe in incrementalism is to
share i think this isn't doing 24 hours
so i think it is an incremental increase
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman um this may end up
being a question from mr mcintyre again
um under the current law
the um
it opens at 8 a.m and closes at 1 00
a.m
um
that's what i just said 11 a.m to 1 a.m
oh did i okay
sorry about that uh so my question is
are there towns out there now who are
restricting it
to stop earlier than 1am
thank you for the question i just asked
my colleague that who actually is in
charge of licensing and the answer is no
we don't know of any talents we're
strict by our the times
okay thank you
representative bernstein
thank you mr chair i just want to remind
the committee of some testimony we heard
last week when we had a public hearing
on this bill and it was either uh mr
newman or mr juve who brought up the
town of hampton and it would be a rainy
summer morning where people wouldn't be
going to the beach
and maybe the gaming facility there
would have a morning tournament
i think the point there was that
they operate in a competitive
environment with
uh gaming facilities in other states
i i don't think it's the role of this
committee to micromanage um i i don't
like
adjusting the hours to 10 a.m that would
preclude the town of hampton from doing
what they think is in their best
interest
as long as the local ordinance trumps
anything that we decide here that's a
built-in safeguard and i think
we shouldn't micromanage we should leave
it up to each town to do what they feel
is best for their town
is that a reply to
a
reptilian yearly followed by
representative nunes
yeah i'm representing bernstein um
local ordinances can't trump state law
they can modify it or add to it unless
we allow within the ordinance
all right within the law the ability of
an ordinance to
do something
then i'll echo your support of
representative aim suggestion to make
that very clear in this
in this legislation
however
go ahead we can't allow local ordinances
to prevent
uh
operating
for less than
there has to be some compromise in some
fashion in there because otherwise we
would allow a local ordinance to say
yeah you can be open from 11 o'clock
until noon
representatives
thank you mr chairman uh just as a
reminder this is enabling legislation
that says may in here
uh and that may says that the towns
still have the right to
to uh form their own guidelines uh i
agree with representative lang
wholeheartedly that uh i know that that
these these types of businesses must go
before
uh their town select boards or city
councils or whatever is to be approved
with a plan that is is completely carved
out for that business at that time and
if they need to change that they have to
go back and talk to them again which is
the same thing as establishing an
ordinance sort of in a more practical
way
the town still has control
via site plan over over the business
so i
i like the bill the way it is i think it
gives an opportunity for uh for workers
all around the state for different and
odd hours that they perform their duties
for the companies they work for to be
able to go out and have the same quality
of life that everybody else has
and they're not cut out from being able
to participate in different activities
because of the
of the shift they either choose or must
work
so i support the bill as it is
representative molly
thank you mr chair uh
that was very helpful representative
nunez about the
word may and their enabling and i think
that is a uh
a good uh i'm glad to be reminded of
that thank you uh so my but my question
to
the group and the chair is this sounds
like a conversation that should be had
in municipal and county government but
not in ways and means so i don't
understand
why we have this bill that's my question
we're the second committee and it
affects revenues
and anything that affects revenues and
we can have an input into the first one
may i think oh we are the first
committee on this yeah
so
then we can do that we're the first
committee i'm sorry
but
so
just to be stickler about it i see no
reference in here to revenue
at all
that there is any anything projected
anything that happens so i'm again i'm
just i'm just asking that question
that's all thank you
yeah
represent malloy
all the charitable gaming bills come to
ways and means
and
charitable gaming does affect our
revenues
even though it doesn't have it
specifically in here
thank you
i appreciate that thank you very much
oh okay representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman good participation
i i think very soon all of us will have
chimed in
i'm sympathetic uh to loosening laws at
state level
um
and i don't mind you know a permissive
expansion of the hours
but at the same time i'm very
sympathetic to the concerns
representative amy has
identified ian lebanon as an example and
uh and to representatives aims concern i
think that
just
taking as a general proposition the
rules of statutory construction
state law does preempt local law and in
a statute that so directly addresses
hours
and then
explicitly identifies the hours
the argument for preemption is probably
at its strongest
so i don't think it would hurt
to just add a phrase
that preserves
or explicitly recognizes what we believe
is already in place where local
municipal ordinances
and more specifically
the actions of local planning boards in
site plan review
are acknowledged and so i see a
compromise
perhaps those who are concerned about
the hours
will
accept
this expansion
if the proviso is clear that a
municipality can shorten them and then i
think both sides win
and and i would just say having been
chairman of charlestown's planning board
that we have no blanket ordinance
that limits operating hours what we do
is we simply
go case by case
based on what's the nature of the
business and the location of the
business primarily
and whether it's a florist shop or a
restaurant or what have you they by and
large all get their own
stipulated operating hours
so
why not let's just if we believe this is
already in law
just make it apparent that we
acknowledge that
elmi
thank you as i understand
site plans
and
the planning board role in this which is
not perfect maybe represents billsbury
can tell me about it
but
you get a site plan
when the building is first occupied
the lebanon
casino is in what used to be a florist
shop which was renting from
on a
on
a
i think that the owner is actually
village pizza which occupies about
most of the upstairs so that they would
be expanding into the basement in order
to do this
which gets temporary renters on it was
not
did not go to the planning board when it
became a poker palace
it's it's a retail establishment that's
what games of chance are treated as
and games of chance were just poker and
people didn't have a real problem with
poker
and now all of a sudden it's something
else
but it still has the same permissive
treatment
that it did before
and there are eight new apparently games
of chance that have already been created
because i heard the other day that there
were 16 of them now there were eight
when you passed this and they're waiting
for the end of that period of three four
years
after which they can convert
to a slot casino
and i live right next to vermont
which doesn't allow any of this stuff
so unlike the massachusetts people
there's nobody they have to compete with
the few people over in vermont that
would want to do this would be over in
our parking lots in winter
purely to clarify i i won't presume that
there's uniform practice in all
municipalities because ordinances can
vary
but i will say that in the town of
charlestown
the change of use provision is explicit
in statute a site plan is required
before developing the property site plan
is required for any major external
modification of the building site plan
is required again
for a change of use and just to give you
an example
a gas station convenience store a couple
of years ago converted to four separate
businesses the planning board required
each
of the four separate units
to present their own site plan for their
business
whether it was a toy store or a
restaurant or a
tattoo parlor
so i
i think that
if we go in the direction
of just simply adding a phrase that
explicitly says this does not preempt
municipal authority
through ordinances
and site plan review
um that we would cover the the matter
and then of course the city of lebanon
would be
able to adjust its ordinance if it
needed to and and what about
grandfathering
well we've been told that because it was
grandfathered because it was a poker
place and now
now it's the same thing
okay uh reps indonesian
thank you mr chairman i i just want to
say that um i agree with representative
nunes that the word may
is enabling in itself and if in this
case
we put in further
words that say that the town
or
has the chance to limit this where else
in state law has the word may been used
that now has to be readdressed i think
the word may
versus the word shall is used throughout
state law so i think here the word may
keeps it uh
enabling thank you
okay um
okay one final comment then i'm going to
try to sum it up
representative run
okay
let's not forget that we're talking
about charitable gaming
the charitable gaming has evolved now in
the last couple of
decades let's say
to be pretty much all-encompassing
we have the historic racing machines
that are going to be coming they're not
slot machines we can have that we've had
that debate over and over again but but
they they
they uh
are a game that's played on a machine
that may be attractive to
customers
the one thing about real casinos true
casinos is that a community
would have to vote that in
or out
either an opt-in or an opt-out
we do not
have opt-in or opt-out
provisions
for
charitable gaming never did never had
and
and so
charitable gaming locations are blessed
by that
they don't have that initial resistance
to opening
because the community can't vote either
way whether they want it or don't want
it
uh so i i'm one saying let's move easy
on this
and let's let's okay let's add another
two hours
um an hour on either end or whatever we
decide half hour whatever uh on either
end and i'm okay with adding the the
language about the ordinance
uh in there as well so i uh i think i
think the proposal to expand a couple
hours
and add the language that i think
representative rulery said or whatever
makes representative ames comfortable
should we should be there should be
added and then we move forward and again
remember
these locations are blessed by not ever
having
to go through
the opt-in or opt-out
question of their communities whether
they want these places or not thank you
okay at this point in time
we have about three different types of
options
roads to go down
one take the
pass the bill as is
or pass the bill of an amendment that
changes the time to expand it
whether it's one hour one and a half
hour
on either end
and the third is
to pass the bill
with a time change
and also clarify
the ordinance part of it
i don't see any other
things being suggested here
so what i want to do is
do a straw vote
and
count the number of hands
those that would are in favor of
passing the bill
as is
okay
those that are in favor of passing the
bill
with a
different time constraint and spelled
out such such as from 10 30
in the morning to 2 30 the following
morning but
we could change the time
those that would be in favor
of expanding the time limit
third one's gonna incorporate the second
one
so
so we got zero for making a time
change well i want a time change but but
i'm waiting for the third option
which is time change plus adding the
ordinance provision
right
the third option is the adding the
ordinance
and making a time change
well i wanted to make a point actually
yeah i do too they're saying that there
might be a fourth option to leave the
times as they are
and add the
the language about the municipalities
have that okay we'll do that one that's
good
i got the number can i change my phone
base
okay
okay then the fourth odd ordinance
is
option
is to
leave the time as is
and add the ordinance
to clarification
is the time that we're talking about the
time that it is currently in statute or
is the time what the bill says there's
the difference there what the bill said
yeah
so mr chair
i i'm going to cautiously raise my hand
here but it's all going to be defined in
how that ordinance language is said
right because we have to be really
careful about how that is i'm a if we
left it we added a provision i'm
completely okay with that but that
language about municipal ordinances to
make sure we don't get the the town that
puts in you can be open from 11 a.m to
12 p.m and that's it so the language on
that ordinance is going to be have to be
extremely tight for me to support it
but i'll raise my hand
mr chairman
yes i want time to go back to my
planning board and find out i don't
think they ever did a renewed site plan
i don't think that when you've got a
building with multiple uses in it that
they do that in my community
which is pretty much up on municipal law
so i would i need time to go back to my
planning board and my city council which
didn't think we did
and find out on
what
our practices are and whether they're
not in
uh
line with everybody else's practices
because we in this case represent i
think those eight places that have been
added as games of chance that are
waiting
waiting to have uh
more on to have
full
use of these
what i call slot machines because you
press the button and they are
but
let me finish
the straw poll thing
yeah
could you give us an idea
what the vote was sure well there's 17
of us here and it looks like uh
32 of us have voted
i i should have said i should have said
you could
vote more than once
it looks like uh requiring or adding the
ordinance language in there is
supported overwhelmingly okay
and then the times um
i have 11 votes for a different time
than is proposed and 10 votes for
leaving the time as is in the
legislation
too many mike wouldn't um
ols be able to give us advice on how to
word it i mean they are all lawyers the
drafting lawyers
ought to be able to come up with words
that are satisfactory
we were counting on it
right i don't think we want to
um
may i make a suggestion on the times
representing
thank you
whoops um
since it was three hours added on each
end in this bill can we split the
difference possibly and do 9 30 and 2 30
and that's three hours added in total
and then that might satisfy the hampton
situation a little better than
how does that the 10 30
that we would have an option
of at splitting the difference on adding
the time
so why don't i
have an amendment
that will do that along with the
ordinance part of it
both of them together
they're both together
because it looks like we need the
ordinance if we
anyway
mr t i do want to and then when you come
back on
thursday that we can discuss that and
hopefully
we can
exec at that point in time
does that sound all right
no
but it's just me i guess but
me and my community and any community
that acts the way we do and my city
manager
was
was half time the lobbyist for nhma
for
five years eight years before he came
to lebanon
i think he knows the laws
but when we do execute on thursday if we
can
then there'll be those that'll be no and
those there'll be those that'll be yes
so um
right
if anybody else has an idea for another
amendment have it ready for thursday
and closing the work session on senate
bill
318.
now i'd like to go something a little
easier
before we get into the
next file
the senate
had amended one of our bills house bill
relative to kino
and we're charged to either come up with
we concur with the senate amendment
or we non-concur
or non-concur and form a committee
conference
and you have in your possession a side
by side
on
house bill 355
and in the side by side there's only one
change made
the senate virgin
version
replaces shall not display kino
web
may display keno
now
how does the committee feel on this
representative
thank you mr chairman and this was if my
memory serves me appropriately this was
the crux of the whole discussion
was the lack of that video screen
we on the southern border are exposed to
what happens in massachusetts as far as
keno parlors okay dotted around the town
of salem are gas stations
small restaurants etc
that people gather specifically to play
keno and and that's
the sole purpose the way this
legislation was presented to this
committee in the uh discussions that we
had relative to this legislation was
it's great because the 7-eleven has to
return a win on a keynote ticket that
was bought someplace else
and they were
deriving no benefit from that
at all this allows for them to
print and sell aquino ticket and get you
know the profit that that they are due
my concern is
these small stores
at l that may become what i see
you know
half a quarter mile from my house
um and clogging up the small store so
what in effect the senate did here was
totally change
the bill that we sent over to him so i
would not support this uh director
mcintyre testified to the to the effect
that it would still bring in and the
numbers hadn't hadn't changed uh five
and a half million dollars in revenue
um and i still stand firm that if people
want to buy their keynote ticket when
they're buying a scratch ticket at the
corner store they can still do that
having that screen changes the whole
dynamic of this so i don't support this
change so i would suggest that if it's a
committee a conference we go that way so
you suggest non-concurrent from a
committee conference yes sir
anybody else
the representative
just to say that i completely agree with
what was what has just been said we
did work on this bill and we
intentionally put in the provision that
uh is now at issue
and uh
i think we did so for good reason so i
just
i stick with it uh i agree with that
and representative romney yes i concur
with the concurrence
and that i think we not concur and ask
for a committee a conference
and i i think what representative
ducette was saying is we're talking
about ted's mobile
we don't want ted's mobiles in the state
because with this bill we could create
tens of mobiles where a convenience
store strips out everything still pumps
gas strips out everything and this has
kino machines in there and we don't want
that
so
i think we fight hard for our original
position of no screens because without
the screens and it wouldn't be the same
so
and this was a compromise from the
original bill
that we we would allow
the convenience stores and restaurants
to offer keynote tickets but not we
don't want people congregating around
the screen waiting for the numbers to
come up so
i i just think we stick together and uh
and and and
say no to the senate on this change
representative
if i remember correctly from the
subcommittee the burden of the the
financial burden would be on
the lottery commission to supply them
if
one of these businesses chose to have it
under this
modification so i think we should not
concur as well
representative yeah the the machines
that are used are the same machines that
all the other lottery products come out
of so i meant the display would on the
display would have to provide it yes yes
thank you
any other comments
so
representative almy
yeah yeah
if
our
is our
everybody seems to agree on this i agree
on this but on if we get into the
committee of conference and they say
uh it's our way or the highway which
what do we say
representative romney you walk away from
the table
that's my
don't go along with it the senate
but we have to threaten that we walk
away from the table
yeah if you if you've done a few of
these over the years it's it's a game of
poker actually
and who's going to blink first but
representative
thank you mr chair
i just i guess i'm struggling again this
is a place where we're taking the
decision away from businesses and i
don't understand why we would not concur
not let a business operate the way it
needs i recognize
that
you know there are some people worried
about kino parlors and kino barns or we
want to call them but the reality is
that these are going to current licensed
lottery locations
if the business owner thinks there's a
value to having a screen up then why
would we deny him the right to do that
why would we say to businesses no we
know that might create increased revenue
for you um i think charlie talk
testified at one point that um on the on
the bars that are currently doing kino
there was up to a 15 lift in revenue
because of because in addition to kino
that there was they were making more
money i i guess i just struggle to see
why the state government is sticking its
nose into a business decision
when a convenience store owner may
choose to do it again i use a little
store in my town that's got a little
sandwich area we can sit and eat if he
thinks that'll increase revenue by
adding a screen in that area why would
we deny him the right to do that what is
you know again we're talking about a six
million dollar lift
in in state revenues uh by by this bill
that we're we're saying we want to walk
away from um in a time when we know that
next year we're gonna get hit with the
interest and dividends first phase of
drawdown and we're gonna have less
revenue i just don't know why
we would be sticking our heels into the
ground and saying no we want to that
it's so important that we take away this
business decision that we were willing
to give up six million dollars in
revenue i struggle to understand why the
ways and committee is there
representative
although i
understand and appreciate representative
lang's uh
position on this it it was clear that
the crux of this legislation
the lack of a better term was sold to me
at least verbally
that
these businesses
that have
access to lottery
aren't
getting any benefit for cashing keno
tickets
okay
if if in fact
we can give them that benefit we can
give them the opportunity to
to get that revenue i'm all for that
this
we could walk down the street of what
you put in your your place of business
that would up business and not
necessarily
every decision is that business owner's
decision what what this is is what i
witnessed at least in my community and
that was the discussion i was privy to
when we talked about it
was it it's it affords the ability
of a patron to come in wanted to buy a
two dollar scratch ticket and i want to
get a two dollar keynote ticket while
i'm here and hey i won a five dollar
keynote ticket let me cash that in and
pay for my two tickets and be off okay
this this totally changes
what what we discussed
and from what i wish commissioner
director mcintyre was still here from
what i understand the revenue
projections remain the same they remain
the same
so
although um
i understand your position
i still stand firm in that
you know
if they want to get the revenue
sell the sell and accept the keynote
tickets but i do not support the screen
thing
any further comments
so
take a straw poll
those that support the amendment that
the senate put on
raise your hand
those that don't support
that's then that's what position so then
we will
non-concur
and form a committee of confidence
and represent the lang you're going to
have your work cut out
all right
we're going to work session on
senate bill 343 establishing a committee
to study room occupancy tax revenue
and fees in the formula for distribution
to municipalities
i had asked
the
dra for some information on this
and
and you've all been handled the hand of
the sheet this has come up a number of
times in the past
and it has gotten nowhere
you give me a pink one
here's anything card it's a committee
right tucker wants to talk though
it's an open discussion you can stay
right where you're at this is a work
session
as a co-sponsor last time i had said
that i would
get specific information about the town
of gorham
which is not in my district
and the town of carroll
which is in my district
carol is
made up of
bretton woods and twin mountain
bretton woods has the mount washington
hotel and all its
condominiums and ski area it's a it's a
major grand resort
and so i did call the
uh town clerk
tax collector
and
i already had of course the town report
so they have this enormous
facility that produces a lot of money i
did find out how much in property taxes
they pay
of course i don't know how much they pay
in meals and rooms because that's not
public information
in the state of new hampshire
but
in
carol got
approximately 61 000
in meals and rooms tax
because they range in population from
to 750 residents
their population
changes
more than most towns because of the
number of people who live at the hotel
and their
spaces and stay for a year or two and
then move on
in
last year they expected to
had an estimated revenues
of 40 000 as they do this year
naturally the hotel was adversely
affected uh as for other
businesses in the town of carroll
by the pandemic so all that they expect
to get
from rooms and meals tax distribution is
forty thousand dollars
now
just to give you a scale of the resort
uh in 2021 they paid 1 million
814 dollars in property taxes
or approximately a fifth of the budget
of the town of carroll
so that's why i think this needs to be
studied
having distribution on population
when there's such a
disparity between the population of the
town
and the size of the
tourist industry
that generates
meals and rooms tax
does not seem as though this was
fair particularly to the north country
those towns north of the notches there
may be many towns that you represent too
that
this is a disparity that seems
not reasonable
in
gorham
they
expected to get
uh
they expect to get this next year
they did get in 2021
206 thousand
535 dollars in rooms and meals tax
they're a town of
2500 maybe 3 000 people
they have
it's a major tourist center they're
working very hard now that the mills are
almost a thing of the past happily not
entirely a thing of the past but
travel and tourism is their major
industry
as we know it's the second largest
industry in the state of new hampshire
and this
seems again unfair considering the
number of
motels restaurants that they have
to
as a way to get state help and
they get
really
very other little state help on the
municipal side naturally on schools they
do get some
so that's why i maintain that this is
worth studying i know that
it's been studied before
but i like to think that rims will make
it possible for
the department of revenue administration
to
be more helpful in
coming up with ways that this could be
better
for towns that have
a large tourist industry
and a relatively small population in the
state of new hampshire
so
i continue to argue that i did bring in
the facts that you asked for
and uh i rest my case
thank you representative tucker
further comments represented
romney
would you take a
question well this is a conversation
so uh when you make when you use the
brentwood uh well not brentwood's the
mount washington hotel example
do you know if that includes brentwood
ski area because they own them yes it
did so it's all including the ski area
that's right i i i talked with the
tax collector on the phone
and she called me back because the
uh whole resort was 61 pages that she
then had to actually add up
there's so many different parcels so
many different businesses
so much involved
in it and
so she was kind enough on her time to
add up all those figures and come up
with this it was not something she
actually knew offhand
it's a huge
uh
investment
right
okay thank you for that mr chair one
more
so
right i think i think we heard uh
dra
say in the hearing
that
that rims really wasn't the issue even
in the past uh can we have can we have
them come up and talk about that again
as to whether rims is really a game
changer here
the dra would you be willing to come up
good morning carolyn lear assistant
commissioner at the department of
revenue administration
so the question is whether we could have
collected this information prior to rims
and i think the answer is yes we could
have
um
it's not really a system issue
it's that the statute
allows for and our rules allow for
consolidated filing
and
that would really need to be undone
before we could fairly ask taxpayers
to schedule out the individual locations
of where revenue is collected
we could have it certainly will be
easier in rims to effectuate those
changes with a new modern shiny system
but we certainly could have effectuated
that previously had the statute allowed
for it
and you would have to run that for a
year or two in order to come up with
the percentages
that's absolutely right and as you all
know the
amount of revenue collected in the
summer versus the winter and the
location where that revenue is collected
in the summer versus the winter is very
different so i think you would certainly
want
um
at least one year but maybe two to
account for all of the other variables
to have decent data on the areas where
revenue was collected
uh representative brown thank you uh so
for the for the filer for the tax filer
it would be just another
addendum that
that would list all the locations and
they would just record
the uh
rooms tax that that was paid in each of
those locations correct
i suspect that's how we would effectuate
it with a schedule we'd still allow one
return but then require the taxpayer to
schedule out the revenue by location i
think the few examples where this could
get especially complex is for the online
platforms um where they may be in all
you know each or almost every
municipality and their schedule could be
quite long in that instance
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman uh it's good to
see you um i'm i want a clarification if
i could from you did you say that our
current statute does not allow and that
that would need to be changed first
before we could move ahead with
something like this
our current statute permits consolidated
return filing and so that would need to
be somehow massaged or modified um to
acknowledge that we do require a
taxpayer to schedule out their income by
location thank you very much
but we do assume that representative
tucker
thank you excuse me
we do assume that
most people who would own a business
that had a variety of locations
actually do know
the differences between
what the business is producing
in the various areas
that that sort of
it would be hard to
imagine that that wasn't true i've
certainly talked with alex ray about
that he he goes over the
the balance sheets every sunday
with the managers at each of the
locations so i think that is what we
really know businesses are doing they do
know what their revenues are at the
various locations
i don't think i'm the right person to
answer that question
further questions or comments
um this is a study committee requesting
for a study committee i think we just
did the study
we now know that it's possible a little
tweaking the law
and if someone wants to file a bill
to
effectuate
these changes
i would say go go for it
i don't think we need a study committee
to do something that we've we've
discussed in this committee over the
years and what's handed out
before you is the list from the from the
dra about the last uh
last
several years since 2015
there have been five bills
discussing this
and each time those bills have been
rejected
i think it's
i don't know what we're going to study i
represent a talker well one of the
things that uh senator hennessey and i i
believe agree on
on this bill is that there may be a
difference
in
whether
there should be the same distribution
of setup
for meals
as there is for rooms
i believe that
particularly north of the notches
the rooms are more lucrative than the
meals
and so i that probably is a five-hour
study with dra but i i think that when
we're talking about the distribution
formula it makes such a difference to
certain towns that i think that is worth
looking at
right now it's the same it's it's a the
multiplier is the population
representative
thank you mr chairman on the one thing
that on
hasn't been studied
studied yet
and that
this committee
shouldn't be studying but a
municipal and county could
is
number five which
uh line 20 assessing the impact of a two
dollar municipal occupancy fee and how
that fee would be reported collected and
managed by a municipality
this was in another bill and the senate
added it to this bill
but
if this study went forward i think that
municipal and county
should be leading it
any anybody else representing gamal
um
i'm a little disturbed that we haven't
heard
that we just needed to change a statute
i mean this is my fourth year here and a
few of these have come through why
didn't we know that
before that we just needed to change the
statute to not allow them to consolidate
but to itemize each of their
individual businesses
i don't know i that just kind of bothers
me just to comment
um
if i may throw a comment in this
is that
if
the rooms and meals are distributed
based upon where the money is collected
then
why couldn't we do that for tobacco tax
do that for liquor
and do that for business
that and i i would think they would all
start getting into the act
and the idea is that uh every time we do
this
then the general fund shrinks
and then we're not able to uh
appropriate
the
right amount to support what we should
be doing
but um
like i live in a town
where it's heavily business because
we're right on the border
and we're also heavy with industry
so
why shouldn't
people in my town be getting more of the
business profits tax
from all these businesses because we
have to provide all the police and the
fire and all the other sort of things so
i think this might open the door for a
lot of things
and take away the idea of
feeding the general fund
just to comment
representation mr chair i think you hit
the nail right on the head um i too i'm
concerned with this bill when we start
looking at you know the municipal
revenue sharing of of various funds you
know the highway tax right our gas taxes
again distributed usually a similar
formula do we now start looking at where
gas stations are versus not and who's
generating the tax um i i am concerned
about opening that door
of starting to appropriate money based
on who raised the money
although represent tucker i'd fully
support if you want to uh look at
raising the distribution amount from the
thirty percent we've increased to two to
the full forty percent i'll be
wholeheartedly get on board with that
idea but the idea of of making it
proportional i think is extremely
problematic
uh further comments representative ames
yeah i just wanted to agree with both
the representative major and
representative lang
i think that uh
when we're talking about uh attacks the
statewide that's
been
intentionally put in place to provide
for statewide needs in some cases some
part of which is
allocated to school fundings in other
cases not
or some cases allocated to highways in
general and then there are formulas that
develop around
that allocation
i think we shouldn't be talking about uh
trying to figure out exactly where the
money came from in the first instance
and saying since i came from there it
should go back to there or some part of
it it
it
it's really a different calculus and uh
so i
i
i er on the side of uh
looking at revenues like the revenues
we're talking about here as
general revenues to the state to be
allocated
according to
formulas and systems and programs that
the state
as a whole determines are
are the best way to use that money
representative spellsberg
yes thank you mr chairman i agree with
the last several comments and i guess i
would just add one more
um
we're dealing with the meals in rooms
tax but what is making this an issue is
the revenue sharing
and i ventured a guess that
if the formula was dramatically changed
there could be some resistance that
would develop to the recent trend
of increasing the revenue sharing
proportion
and it would become less likely
that there would be support
to bring it up from 30 to 40 percent
so there's definitely a tension between
those objectives
any
further comments
um
then
do we need to
continue the work session on this bill
then
is it if um
a
amendment was made to
uh not a motion was made to i tell it
if i take a straw poll
well
let's take a straw poll on that raise
your hand
in favor of idea
mr j is on a motion of itl
if a motion was made right if a motion
was made
we're still in work session
okay it's um
it's the majority is the itl
and so what we will do is when we meet
on thursday
then we will uh open an executive
session on this bill unless
on thursday there's
new information
or more convincing
i'll um
check with my uh
with senator hennessey
see if she has some new information
all right
that will take care of 3 43 until
thursday
the next is a real heavy one
and that's
senate bill 435-fn
relative to the net operating loss
carryover under the business profits tax
and we have with us the dre
and the big thing here
that needs to be understood
is
the double apportionment
that
is what
most of the people here
need to
really understand
and so i think the dre has
can help us out with that
so the dra would come
the dra has provided some information we
also have
some information that was mailed or
provided to you
from representative jim
i can't say the last thing
that's close enough
and i think he did a good job he did
yeah
so we need
okay
thank you
so carolyn if you uh
would
and keen
if
you could enlighten this committee on
the double apportionment
we'll sure try
so i'm actually going to let uh keane um
discuss the example that he crafted for
you all
in hopes of clarifying how this change
would impact
a taxpayer
appointing representatives
i'll just wait for everyone to have a
copy of the uh the handout there was two
sheets right
oh one sheet one sheet right one sheet
one sheet yep okay here's the extras
right so in front of you it's a handout
it's an
example for uh two scenarios
scenario a is with the
current law and scenario b is with the
proposed law of only
having the single apportionment
and so we start off with the scenario a
um
we are assuming that the
claiming the net operating loss
deduction in the tax year of 2021
and that the loss actually originated
from the tax year of 2020
and you see in both scenario a and
scenario b the calculation of the net
out brain loss carry forward is the same
there's no change in that so the net
operating loss that's originated from
year 2020 assuming it was 5 000
and then it's apportioned
subject to the apportionment
for
from that year of the originating loss
assuming that's 0.7
uh apportionment factor
and then you multiply that you'll
probably you'll
arrive at the
3 500 limitation
of available nol to be carry forward
um and then we also will have to compare
with the statutory limitation
uh which at that year is a million
dollars
and the the lower off will be the one
that's going to be carried forward so
which which in this case would be the 3
uh amount that's going to be carried
forward
so in the year of the on the second half
of the uh
of the
example here
for scenario a is if it will be the
the year in which the nol is going to be
uh
deducted so for year 2020 uh tax year
we start off with the federal taxable
income of 10 10 000
and
then you have the net operating loss
deduction
the 3 500 that was calculated earlier
you arrive with the adjusted gross
business profits of six thousand five
hundred dollars
and then
you apply the current year apportionment
assuming that's 0.85 factor
and this is where the double
apportionment happens so it's a portion
in the year of origination as well as
being apportioned now
uh so the 3 500 is going to be a portion
subject to the point the current year
factor apportionment so this is a double
apportionment that everybody's talking
about
and then
you get the
5525 of new hampshire taxable income and
then you multiply that with the
bpt rate of 7.7 percent
whereas on scenario b
that is with just a single apportionment
so the calculation of the
nol deduction of 3 500 is the same
there's no change in that but where the
deduction is applied it will be changed
so you start off with the uh for the
scenario be the bottom half you start
off with the federal taxable income of
ten thousand dollars
and then but you do not
deduct the nol
here
you subject that to the uh regular
apportionment the 0.85 assuming that's
the current year factor of parchment
and then you get the
8 500 and then only you deduct the 3 500
so that 3 500 is only
this it's not subject to another round
of apportionment
and then you calculate the bpt with the
7.7 percent
and so of course the kicker and you know
the the punch line
is obviously in the second scenario the
taxpayer pays less tax ultimately
because the value of their carry forward
nol
hasn't been diluted
by that second round of apportionment
mr chair
can i answer the question then then if
if it goes on go ahead and followed by
representing ames oh i'm sorry
so if if this goes on if there's still
uh and lost carry forward for the third
the next year
this same thing happens it compounds
itself going forward
it wouldn't compound itself going
forward because if you don't
use that nol
in a particular year that second round
of apportionment
doesn't happen
so
you would if if you
in year two didn't have any income to
offset and so you carried that nol into
year three it would be the year three's
apportionment percentage that would
apply the second time okay thank you
representatives
this uh thank you uh
makes sense to me and
what i'm puzzled over is
why
why there has been
double enforcement in the past what is
sit in the statute that
has led us in this direction because i
don't see it
oh gosh
i could rather than misspeak or hold you
up i would um i can email you the actual
analysis that we performed but i think
it's fair to say
that it wasn't
i don't believe it to have been a
purposeful policy decision
i suspect it was more
an unintentional way that the wording
was drafted
because as you heard previously this is
not the way that any other state
apportions an nol um so i can't imagine
we were at that time making a purposeful
decision to do something different
yeah so so that being the case i have no
objection whatsoever to
clarifying
that this is not
that there is not to be a double
apportionment
calculation and
uh so i see that as a clarification or
as a fix is what we talked about
a week ago
and there's a second part of this bill
let me think about this
there are two parts to this bill for
sure the second part is the date
and
and the date is all important because it
changes
from one federal code
definition of uh
of how carry carryover
what's it carry forward
uh
uh losses are to be
limited
uh
and goes to a different provision
there's more
well it's both more generous and more
restrictive uh
of businesses there's an 80 limitation
and a uh
lifting of all
uh
cumula the the aggregate amount is is
unlimited um
uh and that's a different discussion
uh and i i don't know okay
tell me perhaps this is this is my
question uh do we have a do we have a
estimate of
what we might lose
if we go to that
new system
so
you're asking is there an estimate of
the impact of updating our reference to
the internal revenue code yeah yes it's
about four i believe four and a half
million in additional revenue
it's in the
yeah i i didn't have time to look back
at that so thank you that's the last
page yeah
of the bill that mr chair just want to
clarify
representative romney so just for
clarity
there's two pieces of the bill as
representative ames said that are really
independent of each other just happened
to be in the same bill
so there's so no confusion here the the
section one
line one through line
six is one thing we just discussed in
the line 7 to line 14
is the second second thing that we have
to discuss
i think we just got the explanation that
that this
has been a historic
misinterpretation of our statue
for hour long for a long time
and
and that that that i think we understand
now what that is now we have to talk
about the second piece we want to change
the theory wasn't a misinterpretation is
that the statue was screwed up and it
was interpreted the way the statue says
go ahead yes
yeah
because of liability
right i apologize for that put it
differently we don't have to pin it down
we just need to uh
clarify for the future how's that
all right
um
so are we all set on the double
apportionment
representation
sorry the statutory limitation
is 1 million
is that somewhere in our law still
1 million a year
i i think it was a missing zero in the
example
what
i missed what she said
it's currently 10 million 10 million
yeah
and and that's shown in the table
that was sent to us from
the cpi cpa
no there's a footnote in the middle
which i can't pronounce his last name
right and
it shows
it shows what limitations there were in
all the states and
for instance
massachusetts
has a 20 million dollar
yeah
i mean 20-year carried forward i'm sorry
you have no limitation
right
but they don't depend on business taxes
the way we do
thank you mr chair um mr chair i was
thinking of of an amendment here to
clean up some some of this especially
we're talking between lines 9 through
lines 24.
um we know that lines 15 through
22 no longer even apply and i'm not sure
why we want to just keep carrying
forward dead language in our bill and
our statute that just confuses people
stop stop right that's good
um the dra
is is that a correct statement
line 15 through
22-22
no longer apply yes um
so romans 13 a b c
and d
no longer apply
primarily because of the 10-year carry
forward there's no way anyone's claiming
an nol today
using those limits
go ahead thank you mr chair so
the second thing i was i was
i was hoping open for discussion is on
line 13 where we have the 10-year limit
as we know as you just said mass has a
20-year limit
i think the feds were unlimited um and
and while i know i don't want to touch
the 10 million dollar cap
i i do think it would be appropriate to
at least take a a step towards further
compliance so we're kind of all in
alignment and have that 10-year change
to a 20-year in talking with dra it
didn't sound like that was going to have
any significant impact on revenues
although would bring us closer to
compliance and having a more uniform
method
that all other states use so businesses
aren't uh dealing with our one-offs
may i make a comment go ahead answer
first and then i'll make a comment
so um
with respect to
the
dollar value of the cap as well as the
duration of the carry forward
it's going to be nearly impossible for
us to accurately predict the fiscal
impact of changing either of those
primarily because it's dependent upon
whether or not the taxpayer
will ultimately have a liability to
offset in the future and when you're
talking 10 or 20 years into the future
that taxpayer might not even be in
existence anymore um let alone have a
liability to offset i and as
representative lang and i talked the one
thing that
i would say is it's hard for me to
envision there being a large number of
businesses who are carrying
a sustained loss over the course of 20
years
um so i imagine that it would be as you
go through time it's going to be rarer
and rarer if that's a word to um to see
a taxpayer reach that 20-year
time frame and actually
recognize that loss on a return if
they've sustained it for such a long
duration
and to further understand that carry
forward amount of loss
that's limited to 10 million dollars
that's 10 million dollars in year one
but let's say you're developing
something in year two you have another
10 million dollars
then your total
would be 20 million
and then your three
develop another 5 million then your
total would be 25 million and it takes
but you can't carry the nol forward more
than 10 million
more than 10 years then you would start
no 10 million dollars
for one year but
so in year one you have 10 million
dollars
year two you develop another 10 million
dollars you can only use that you can
only use 10 million okay okay okay so uh
and it's probably not
that probably wouldn't happen but unless
you were extremely large company and
you're
ramping up
but don't forget that
representative spellsbury
yeah just to clarify that online's um 23
and 24 the words is the amount of net
operating loss generated in a tax year
that may carry be carried forward may
not exceed 10 million so
that's clear in the statute just as
chairman major described it
i i don't
actually see
uh clear grounds i apologize for being
absent at the hearing last week but i
did listen to the entire hearing
i didn't hear strong grounds for
extending
the period from ten years
it
probably would be relatively harmless
because i think there are very few cases
where a carry forward loss
has not been recaptured and applied
against uh
gains in ten years uh and i think that
the way that this question arose during
the hearing
was due to the fact that
conformity with the federal
code
would change
from
100 to 80 percent and so people were
concerned
that the 10 years becomes more
problematic
if coupled with an 80 percent limit
but even looking through the various
examples that we've received which i
thought were very helpful from jim's
yuseglio
and others that i just scratched out you
know on on scratch paper it's very hard
to see how somebody would not be able to
uh
apply their losses to future gains
within a 10-year span even with the 80
cap
you have to be losing money year after
year
in order to get yourself uh that far
down the road and in that case your
business probably has failed in advance
so again i i didn't in the hearing
and i didn't in my own
uh modeling
come up with what the issue is what the
problem is i'd be perfectly fine
accepting the
result of 80 cap and leaving the 10
million cap in place
the 80
cap is is a uh
what do you call
a
gliding effect a smoothiness effect on
total taxes because if you're around
long enough you're going to recover all
the nol
yes i think that what mr yuseglio's
model does clearly show
is that it might take you a year or two
longer
to fully avail yourself if your loss
carry forwards
and as you say it's it has a smoothing
effect
so i wouldn't be strongly in favor of
making a modification i think
the bill actually hits a pretty good
balance as it is
further comments
representative bromney yeah i did a
little i did a little graph on that
graph a little chart for myself
so our current law 10 years
10 000 max per year
addition to the no
10 year period in which to use it
and we have no 80 percent provision
federal law
of the last federal law
says
max is unlimited
there's no 10-year limit it's unlimited
but they do have the 80 percent you have
to use eighty percent
you can use up to eighty percent every
year for the loss
and the bill
does
keeps our ten years keeps our ten uh ten
ten million max
and it adopts the eighty percent
so
i i'm i'm with you representative
pillsbury i think the bill as written
is probably where we want to go because
the 80 does
tend to temper it down a little bit in
terms of impact
on our our taxes and actually
this does lead to additional revenue
as we we heard
uh in the short run i mean eventually
that whole and it's all it's all taken
but um so i think the bill has written
is is where'd it go
any further comments representing
early brought up regarding
15 through 22 is that right 15 through
22 yes
that could be just
yes
everybody agree to that
representatives you just want to check
on this the it lines uh
21 to 22 that's where the 1 million
limit is
which is
in effect
um
about you know
all right
just checking
good
we're coming back on thursday
so we'll have the amendment
but i want to know is do we need
anything else
representative schamberg chair i have
two questions one for representative
abrami and then one for the tra
are you suggesting then that we adopt
both the
uh
federal 80 percent
and with the
indefinite carry forward is that what
you were suggesting by your example
people keep our 10 years in our 10
million
okay so it's not adopting 100 of what
the fed's current feds are saying okay
all right my second question uh to the
dra
you mentioned that you couldn't see a
company staying in business
if they continue to lose lose lose
if a company or a subsidiary
of a multinational
location somewhere else
would they be able to
the subsidiary stay in business here
and
show this
loss year after year after year
and still stay in business if they're
part of a multinational
i'm looking at keane who's a former many
years auditor in the department of
revenue with real experience with
taxpayers
and it has to do with transfer pricing
is where i'm looking at this
maybe you can work on it on answers
mr chair i didn't mean to stump anybody
no i i think i was trying to listen to
keane and sort of think of how to boil
it down um i think the answer is
certainly yes that you know there could
be a subsidiary in a combined business
that perpetually generates losses but is
kept afloat
because of the otherwise successful
nature of the businesses and the
combined group but i also think that
there are
business practicalities
that would prevent the combined group
from allowing that to happen over a
sustained duration i would never say
that it wouldn't happen but it to me
doesn't seem like a trend you would see
happen
any further questions or comments
then would you or
lying
would you get the amendment so i'm doing
the amendment to strike lines 15 through
move section e to the end of line 14 so
it reads for the taxable period ending
on before july january 1st 2013.
and that's the only thing we're going to
change
and we're going to have that ready for
thirds got the email going ask ols right
now
any further questions or comments on
anybody else wish to
add anything else
then we're going to close the work
session on
house bill
435.
carolyn is going to be leaving him yeah
then i have one more thing about army
um
i do have some sad news
in that
you know over the
last couple years whenever we had the
dre and
they've been excellent
since i've been here
there hasn't been a
better group to work with
now carolyn
is going to be on
on her way to a much better job
she's going to be leaving us she's going
to washington
and we wish her the best but
i'm sad that she's leaving because she's
been very good to us
so
she's going to work for the irs
she's going to keep an eye on us so
understand that our code is probably
this this this high
their code is like
that
and they're way underfunded are you sure
you wanted to represent nunes uh thank
you mr chairman uh ms leer i've i've
only known you for two years and you've
been a delight to work with and very
informative in everything that we've
talked to you about so i certainly wish
you well uh but i know that that
everyone will miss you
thanks for those comments
and uh
representative yes um
some of you may know that representative
ames and i and senator guida
uh are on the uh tax expenditure
uh report uh review committee
and we finally got around to looking at
army and some of you who were here
some may not know what army oh yeah
advanced uh regenerative manufacturing
institute
and uh that's dean cayman's
um operation
in the in the middle yard in in
manchester
and what army
he got a 60 million dollar department of
defense
uh grant
to pull together all the science that
relates to
basically growing body parts growing
organs
kidneys let's say pretty exciting stuff
and he wanted to do it here in new
hampshire um
but for him to stay he asked the
legislature to do something that we
really don't do very often and give
pretty major tax breaks
to small companies to attract small
companies here to become part of what
they call their ecosystem
and he's because the knowledge is out
there and he go he went and raided
you know cambridge to get the phds that
have the onesie twosie companies that
are developing something here and
somebody else some people say he's
trying to track those companies so
we had a long process
where we
we looked at this
and we agreed
to give ten for over a ten-year period
to give tax breaks
to army any of these new companies would
not pay business tax b-e-p-p-t or b-e-t
for ten years
and then you know so but if you came in
year four you would have six years of
tax breaks that's the way it worked
but the second part of the bill was to
give tuition
uh forgiveness
to
uh people who came as well and that was
in the form of forming a fund for for
donations to be put into
or even the state to fund
some out of the general fund
as well as giving the bonding authority
to bond up to five million dollars
worth
so
it's been five years
we finally got around to it
we we it took me a while to get uh
maureen tui from army
who's executive director to appear
and then but for the tuition part it's
it's uh james key wallace who heads the
new hampshire business finance authority
and they had the responsibility for
creating the tuition program
so we had him go first
he says okay where are we well we got
all the structure made we got it all
done
because we have no funds
we haven't done five years not one one
penny's gone out not one penny's been
raised not one penny's gone out
so i looked at representative hames i
looked at senator gaida i'm tearing this
and
said is this news to you yep news to us
so then
uh miss uh tui comes up from army and
says you know we really do need this
you know like and they're looking at us
like why have we done something but it's
like where have you been five years you
haven't no one's blown the whole whistle
that
that this hasn't been funded
uh at any rate
so what's happening and i'll get to the
second part of the of the the tax break
part
the
so senator guida jumped on it
he got he
did an amendment he was going to put on
a labor bill his bill that's in labor
so i saw i saw um
i saw um
i said that's the wrong place so i met
with uh
representative berger thank you
and i said you know this is what's going
to happen he says no no no no put it on
senate bill 409
it's in my committee there's a hearing
on thursday
and this is by the way increase the 5
million from the main whatever find him
wants to do
so we're going to take care of that
we're going to fund this thing
now on the on the senate part this the
uh excuse me the second the first part
really is the is tax break
so
the department of revenue is still kind
of here you're here back there
so first i tried to get some numbers out
of department of revenue but since
there's
there's the 10 limit 10 year 10
10 company threshold has not been met
so they won't give us any not even the
total because of their rules which just
makes sense
but from the testimony it sounded like
and help me out dick
that army army is applying itself to
corporate and then the subcommittee they
have a subcorporation that they're also
applying for these tax breaks
but then it's she said
it's probably up to six other small
companies that have applied that may
are eligible to apply but she doesn't
know if they have a blog because they're
private businesses they haven't she
hasn't
so
so there's upwards of eight
companies that may may or may not be
taking advantage of this
and then those those six are very small
she goes those six are small
and they're not and it's safe to say
they're not making money
okay so there's no business profit sex
but there is bet
which is not going to be much so in five
years this after all the time we spent
not much money has
been
allocated to this or these tax breaks
haven't been taken advantage of
so
representative ames and i and uh and
senator guy are going to
may look at making some recommendations
on that program as well
out of this that's the whole idea of
this
of this committee is to look at a
different
education tax break and this kind of tax
break and this kind of tax break
to see if it's being used or not and
this one
needs a little bit of a boost i don't
think we want to get rid of it or can't
get it but
i think we're going to work from that
dick you want to kind of add a little
color to that
i suppose just to say three cheers for
the tax credit
subcommittee or committee uh it is it is
a way of monitoring what happens after
we enact a bill and uh in this case we
uh
caught something and uh
and uh
we're struggling you know it's new
information and i don't think
any one of us has uh
had time to really sit down and
figure this all out and i think we're
going to have to
bring army back in
to
to further consider this but it's a good
process
representative
help me
thank you the reason that there is no
money in there is that we decided at a
time when there wasn't really enough
money in the budget and such
on that on
we were going and on
the
head of new head of business
housing authority had experience with
uh raising money privately
and he agreed to this that he would make
an attempt
to raise enough money to pay for that
tuition program
so there was a fund that was supposed to
be funded by that he seems to have
forgotten that he agreed to that
proposal at the time
uh in order to keep it in there because
army wanted it dean came and wanted it
um
and
we um the bill in labor
which
is totally inappropriate for labor but
somehow got there on is a bill to ju
simply to guarantee
that senate and house ways and means
committees would get the annual report
from army
which has not been coming
and uh
so i think somebody needs to go
over to labor
and
point out that on would you please pass
this even though you don't understand it
it has nothing to do with what labor
does yeah i'll talk i'll i'll talk to
them
and but again the the the amendment is
for the money is going to be attached to
409 which is a finance bill much more
appropriate but i agree they should pass
this but it was in the original by the
way in the in the original statute
it did add army to the
what's to be reviewed by the um
taxation you know yeah
expenditure
we followed through in and out anyway
right but i hope that the whole
committee will get the report when we
managed to get a hold of it we've been
wondering for quite some time
what was going on and i i do think um
the amendment that senator gaida has
is for a tax break every
year
on
for
for a tax credit i think it is for a
million no it's an appropriation for a
million dollars every year
and
i do think since we have money now but
we may not have money next term and the
term after that we need to make sure
that
if it's five million that's it
yeah if it's if it's a one minute a year
and then for five years
okay well i'm just saying i'm going to
go to the hearing on thursday afternoon
i think it's a two o'clock or three
o'clock something like that on 409 where
the money's going to be talked about
i'll try to get there too because
we
we did this together at that point mary
beth
thanks so i'm on finance yes and my
question is
my recommendation is first of all you do
5 million this term don't try and spread
it out because we all know you can't
legislate into the future if you don't
get the 5 million now you may never see
any more
and two it's it's that's my question is
how much is in the amendment that
they're trying to push through the
kieran said she shepard through finance
um
and it's five is she saying five this
year or one a year what is she
recommending she told me i had a hallway
conversation with representative romberg
first it's going to division two you
division two i'm not i'm division one
yeah but it's going to division two uh
hearing in division two
and no i said a million dollars
because that's what
god i was looking for senator god is
looking for uh suggesting and then
she'll no no
ask for five minutes and ask for it this
year just like you said
which is going to happen yeah i i would
agree i think i didn't understand
everything that was going on but karen's
giving you really good advice you get
the 5 million now where you're not going
to see it
well thank you on
both
representative ames and
romney for that
anything else
could i just add on to that
they
they're having a hard time getting
these businesses going
and they've only got six of them now
and they may be having a hard time
getting
the young people that would take these
credits
here
and
do we give them the 5 million
and lapse it in five years which the
original idea was that they're going to
use it in five years or do we give them
give them the 5 million this is for
finance
and
and just say until it's gone you can
keep using it
or until you close this down which i
hope won't happen but
those are good questions
represented yearly
yeah um we're getting towards the end of
the year um
wants to leave early
so we're going to leave early too
the question is do we want to get
together
in
may or june
just to have a social
with our
significant others
that's a good idea
and
i would think that
we went to marquis once
it's a very nice little meal
and the only thing i need is
for somebody to come up with some dates
okay
don't feel too comfortable
or get too comfortable
because the senate goes in session this
coming week
and
they have a whole slew of bills
so
we may be
getting a few more
i'm just saying now is the time to start
thinking about someday whether we want
to do a debate or do we want to do it
june i think june would probably be more
appropriate
june sounds like a good time but uh do
we do new revenue projections too
do we do new revenue projections before
the end of the term we will be doing
updated revenue
estimates after april thank you
and we're going to be doing a few other
things relative to revenues
oh
i don't know where that is
yeah but we may be getting pretty soon
yeah
it's going to have to be fun
we have other things to do
regarding revenue does that mean we're
going to go up to albany and look at the
gold mine
you can do that for us
um
there is a
bill
where the
senate attacked on the gas tax
uh forgiveness thing forgetting this for
two months
and
i sat in on that testimony i didn't
testify
but it didn't go very well and i don't
think that's going to survive and i hope
it doesn't
because if we get it
i hope it doesn't survive out of this
committee
okay
all right
then
we will see you thursday
10 o'clock
uh thursday
at nine o'clock we'll have a caucus of
republicans in room 104.
yes
he got replaced with yeah